j'aime les abeilles j'aime les abeilles
parce qu'elles nous ont toujours apporté
la lumière
tout d'abord celle qui est clair et qui
permettait de rendre la nuit acceptable
il faut se souvenir d'un temps pas si
lointain où l'énergie électrique
n'existait pas dès que le soleil se
couchait
il ne restait sur la terre que les
ténèbres et pour s'opposer à ces
ténèbres
l'homme ne disposait que d'une seule
chose la flamme celle du feu dans un
premier temps et ensuite celle de la
bougie qui permettait de partager la
lumière de la diviser de la répartir
dans un espace en septembre dernier je
suis parti en montagne seul j'avais
beloin besoin de m'éloigner de la
compagnie des hommes pendant quelques
jours
j'ai commencé par cheminer sur un
sentier de grande randonnée est très
rapidement j'ai bifurqué dans un petit
vallon qui me paraissaient sauvage après
seulement quelques heures de marche
loin de tout sentier j'avais
l'impression d'être le seul au monde
le premier à découvrir ce territoire
j'ai ensuite marcher à flanc de montagne
pour atteindre la crète et lorsque le
soir est arrivé je suis redescendu vers
la forêt pour y chercher un abri et y
passer la nuit
j'ai trouvé deux gros rocher avec une
cavité est un espace suffisant pour y
construire un feu est installé mon duvet
et c'est effectivement la première chose
que les fait allumer ce feu et plusieurs
fois dans la nuit
je me suis réveillé pour ajouter du bois
et faire en sorte que cette petite
flamme ne s'éteigne pas
je n'avais pas froid j'avais un bon
duvet il n'y avait pas de danger mais
j'avais besoin de ce petit cocon de
lumière sécurisant pour rendre les
bruits de la nuit acceptable
éteignez toutes les lumières des villes
une seule nuit est passé cette nuit sans
flamme sans feu 100 bougies sans cette
bougie fait à partir de cire d'abeille
et vous comprendrez que ce cadeau que
nous on fait les abeilles pendant des
millénaires est un cadeau spécial est
merveilleux très jeune j'ai été attiré
par les abeilles
je me souviens de mes premières émotions
de la curiosité qui s'est emparée de moi
quand un apiculteur est venu installé
ses ruches à proximité de la maison de
mes parents je me souviens des longues
heures que je passais observer c'est
abel la rencontre la première rencontre
a été assez brutale puisque vers l'âge
de 8 ans j'ai décidé d'aller ouvrir
l'une de ses ruches sans protection j'ai
été piqué des dizaines de fois et j'ai
terminé à l'hôpital mais c'est aussi ce
jour là que j'ai été piqué par la
passion la passion des abeilles qui
devait surgir plus de 25 ans plus tard
et donner naissance un beau projet une
belle entreprise une entreprise spéciale
est merveilleuse dont je m'occupe accord
aujourd'hui c'est donc en 2007 que j'ai
senti à nouveau cet appel un besoin très
très fort d'aller vers les abeilles
j'en ai parlé à mes amis j'en ai parlé à
ma famille et tout le monde était un
petit peu surpris
et un soir j'ai reçu un coup de
téléphone de l'un de mes amis qui
m'annonçait qu'un essaim d'abeilles
était venu s'installer à quelques
centaines de mètres de ma maison sur un
rond point à l'entrée de mon village je
n'étais pas habitué heures je ne savais
pas comment faire mais tout ce dont je
me souvenais c'est que si j'allais voir
ses abeilles sans protection j'irai
dormir à l'hôpital j'ai donc contacté un
apiculteur qui m'a passé une tenue de
protection qui m'a donné aussi quelques
conseils et je suis rentré chez moi j'ai
construit une petite ruche avec un vieux
carton que j'avais dans mon garage et je
suis allé présenter aux abeilles par
chance elles l'ont accepté
ça y est j'étais devenu apiculteur
durant les mois qui ont suivi cette
nouvelle rencontre avec les abeilles
je suis allé les observer presque tous
les jours et je ressentais une énergie 9
une envie de changement
que je n'arrivais pas bien expliqué au
début je comprenais que ma vie ne
battait pas son plein et j'avais un
sentiment de fragmentation d'un côté mes
rêves d'enfant mes aspirations
personnelles et de l'autre ma vie
d'adulte raisonnable je comprenais qu'il
me manquait le contact avec la nature
il me manquait d'attendre avec
impatience le printemps d'espérer les
floraisons et de me réjouir avec les
abeilles quand elle arriverait il me
manquait aussi un environnement de
travail plus simple moins hiérarchique -
administratif je comprenais que l'homme
était avant tout un animal un bel animal
intelligent et créatif et que pour
laisser cette nature authentique
s'exprimer il fallait moins de contrôles
plus de liberté et je rêvais d'une belle
entreprise dans laquelle chacun puisse
conserver sa à son énergie cette belle
énergie pour de vrai projet de vrais
combats et non pour assister à des
réunions répondre à des demandes
hiérarchique ou remplir des tableaux de
bord et c'est ce que nous avons tenté de
créer avec mon associé olivier nous
avons créé un toit pour les abeilles une
entreprise dont le coeur de métier la
préservation des abeilles en premier
lieu nous avons proposé aux particuliers
et aux entreprises de parrainer des
ruches et de s'engager en leur nom dans
la protection des abeilles
en quelques mois nous avons convaincu
des milliers de particuliers
des centaines d'entreprises et créer un
vaste réseau d'apiculteurs qui couvre
aujourd'hui toute la france mais c'est
surtout dans son mode de fonctionnement
que cette entreprise allait trouver son
originalité et ce sont les observations
des abeilles les contacts avec les
abeilles qui nous ont amenés à repenser
ce mode de fonctionnement de
l'entreprise
la première chose que nous avions
observé c'était cet essaimage cette
boule d'abeilles qui était venu où se
poser au milieu de ce rond point
je ne comprenais pas pourquoi ces
abeilles avaient quitté leurs ruches
j'ai fait des recherches sur internet
j'ai lu des textes et j'ai surtout
entendu la première belle histoire que
venait de me raconter les abeilles
l'essaimage est un moment très
particulier de la vie de la colonie
d'abeilles c'est le moyen naturel de
multiplication des colonies d'abeilles
dans la nature dans la nature on parle
de fièvre d'essaimage parce que rien ne
l'arrête la vieille reine accompagnée
par la moitié des abeilles vont quitter
la ruche dans l'incertitude et le
dénuement dénouement dénuement le plus
total
en laissant aux générations futures la
totalité des ressources
le miel la cire la propolis et la ruche
qui va permettre à la jeune reine rester
sur place avec l'autre moitié des
abeilles de donner naissance aux
générations futures et de les élever
dans de bonnes conditions
quel exemple extraordinaire pour l'être
humain qui a choisi s'approprier de
façon immédiate toutes les ressources de
la planète
quittant privé les générations futures
mais de ces observations nous avons sur
surtout tiré un autre enseignement
directement applicables à la vie de
l'entreprise celui de la force ii l'envi
au fil du temps j'ai constaté que les
colonies qui partait s'aimer et elle est
plus forte qu'elle résistait à tout aux
intempéries aux maladies et aux
parasites aux agressions extérieures et
qu'elle se développe et coûte que coûte
cette vieille reine et ses abeilles elle
ne partait pas avec désespoir mais au
contraire avec une joie altruiste une
envie très forte
un projet commun une vision commune
celle de bâtir une nouvelle cité et de
la faire prospérer et c'est la force de
cette vision qui rendait cette colonie
d'abeilles si robuste
nous avons donc décidé de prendre en
compte la force de l'envi comme le
moteur principal du développement de
notre entreprise
et si ces abeilles incarner cette envie
inaltérable aussi forte c'est parce
qu'elle avait choisi librement et sans
contrainte de s'engager dans cette
aventure
la moitié des abeilles étaient restés
dans la ruche avec la la jeune reine
et l'autre moitié s'étaient lancés dans
cette aventure spéciale est merveilleuse
en l'ayant choisi pleinement si nous
voulions laisser cette envie se déployer
dans l'entreprise il fallait donc avant
tout que nous apportions plus de liberté
plus d'autonomie à chacun et c'est ce
que nous avons choisi de faire
nous avons par exemple décidé qu'il n'y
aurait plus d'obligation de travailler
depuis un lieu précis chacun serait
libre de travailler depuis l'entreprise
mais aussi depuis chez soi depuis un
bureau partagé ou depuis n'importe où en
france nous avons aussi proposé que
chacun puisse organiser sa journée en
fonction de ses engagements
professionnels bien évidemment mais
aussi en fonction de ses besoins
personnels besoin de se reposer durant
la journée d'aller faire du sport
organisation de la vie de famille
rendez-vous personnel tous ces besoins
font maintenant partie des plannings de
chacun sans qu'aucun contrôle ne soit
apportée et on retrouve aujourd'hui dans
tous les process de l'entreprise cette
méthode des abeilles cette liberté cette
autonomie qui sont à mon sens l'un des
principaux vecteur de motivation dans
l'entreprise mais si nous voulions
laisser le talent de chacun explosé il
fallait aller plus loin et ce sont à
nouveau les abeilles qui nous ont montré
une voie possible
en observant cet essaimage d'un peu plus
près nous nous sommes aperçus qu'il
était riche d'un autre enseignement qui
allait nous amener à repenser les
mécanismes de prise de décision dans
l'entreprise l'absence totale de chefs
et de hiérarchie dans une ruche on a
tendance à croire qu'une ruche est très
hiérarchisé avec une organisation quasi
militaire
en fait c'est tout simplement linverse
il y règne un réel principes
démocratiques et un partage des
décisions entre toutes les abeilles
revenons donc à notre essaimage la
moitié des abeilles
accompagné par cette vieille reine
viennent de quitter la ruche de se
regrouper à quelques dizaines de mètres
de là pour former une grappes d'abeilles
un essaim des éclaireuses vont ensuite
partir dans toutes les directions pour
explorer le territoire et découvrir un
lieu d'accueil
définitif un tronc d'arbre creux une
cavité qui pourra se trouvait à
plusieurs kilomètres de là et ensuite
tous les saints va décoller pour aller
s'installer dans ce lieu définitif
nous avons donc des dizaines d'
éclaireuses qui partent dans des
dizaines de direction qui reviennent
avec des centaines d'informations
qu'elles vont partager avec des milliers
d'abeilles et à l'issue de ce processus
de décision il ne restera qu'une seule
information qui sera vital pour la
colonie une information qui devra être
partagé par tout le monde est accepté
par toutes les abeilles le lieu
définitif d'installation si on observe
la surface de cet essaim on y voit des
groupes d'abeilles qui danse
c'est par ce moyen que les abeilles vont
partager l'information et surtout
prendre des décisions cette découverte a
été faite par un scientifique du nom de
fans friche qui a obtenu un prix au un
prix nobel pour avoir compris ce langage
des abeilles et ce langage des abeilles
est très précis dans notre cas les
abeilles vont pouvoir par exemple
indiqué la direction au degré près la
distance au mètre près et la qualité du
lieu d'accueil potentielles pour la
colonie à chaque danse correspond une
information spécifique et comme chez les
êtres humains certaines abeilles vont
faire preuve d'un esprit de conviction
plus fort que les autres car elles sont
sûrs que leurs idées la bonne elle
incarne cette certitude et ses abeilles
là vont danser de façon suffisamment
persuasifs pour entraîner avec elle
d'autres abeilles dans cette danse et
certaines de ses autres abeilles vont
partir pour vérifier que ce lieu est
bien le lieu spécial et merveilleux
attendu par toute la colonie et si c'est
le cas elles vont rentrer avec la même
joie danser avec autant de persuasion et
entraîner à nouveau d'autres abeilles
dans leurs danses peu à peu les autres
danses vont s'éteindre l'unité va se
faire et les saints va décoller le
groupe davaï va décoller pour aller
s'installer dans sa danse ont lieu
définitif
on voit que dans ce processus
il n'y a aucune hiérarchie pas de chef
pas d'abeilles avec un rôle spécial
c'est ce que nous avons tenté de mettre
en place dans notre entreprise
chacun est maintenant libre d'arriver
avec une idée de l'expliquer aux groupes
de susciter l'adhésion
et si cette idée réussi justement à
susciter l'adhésion du groupe
elle se transformera en projet en
quelques années ce mode de
fonctionnement cette méthode des
abeilles nous a permis de lancer des
projets très variés un toit pour les
abeilles avec l'installation de
plusieurs milliers de russes chaque
année en france des fleurs dans la
vallée qui va permettre de préserver la
biodiversité en ce moment chaque année
des centaines de milliers de mètres
carrés de fleurs sauvages une marque
cosmétique à partir de produits de la
ruche un conservatoire de l'abeille une
coopérative solidaire au maroc un
service de partage de jardin un
conservatoire de l'abeille etc
et c'est cette méthode
cette méthode des abeilles qui permet à
chacun de se sentir impliqué de
travailler avec indépendance liberté de
partager les décisions peu d'animaux
sont à même de déstabiliser tout
l'édifice de la vie sur terre
l'abeille et l'être humain partagent
cette responsabilité
par son action de pollinisation
l'abeille participe à la reproduction de
plus de 80% des plantes à fleurs sans
elle nous assisterions un véritable
chaos végétales et animales et en
quelques années ce serait 75% de nos
cultures et de notre alimentation qui
disparaîtrait grâce à cette
pollinisation elle a su mettre en place
une stratégie intelligente qui sert ses
intérêts personnels mais qui profite
aussi à la nature dans son ensemble plus
la bei travail plus elle va chercher le
nectar qui fera son miel et plus elles
pollinisent et puis elle participe à
l'accroissement de la masse végétale
c'est aussi par son travail que l'être
humain peut tenter de changer le monde
en appliquant dans l'entreprise les
principes de la ruche l'autonomie
l'indépendance la liberté et surtout le
partage des décisions nous laissons une
chance
à l'émergence d'une envie forte d'un
projet commun celui de bâtir notre
nouvelle cité notre nouveau monde de le
faire prospérer et de transmettre aux
générations futures les ressources
disponibles
merci